from Los Angeles California the 70th
anniversary Academy Award the stars are
out tonight in all their glory to
celebrate Oscars 70th anniversary here
at the Shrine Auditorium in Los Angeles
and the movie fans have been gathering
since early this morning to catch a
glimpse of them and here are the stars
they have come to see to Hollywood
legends Elise Ryder and Roddy McDowall
who else would share first-time Oscar
nominee Greg Kinnear Joan Cusack
Supporting Actress nominee
[Music]
thanks dr. recipient redundant vent
Inslee
[Music]
the beautiful new rear end Sharon Stone
Marlee Matlin Oscar winner for Best
Actor Samuel al Jackson presenting
tonight Gloria Stewart nominated
Supporting Actress for Titanic at old
was nominee ever Amistad timer to ensue
with Hollywood's top reporter haami
Orchard
[Music]
oscar-winner for network
Minnie Driver nominee burglar hunting us
termina nominated to the apostle
barbecue law elegant actress Sigourney
Weaver
- oscar-winners Holly Hunter and Frances
McDormand
Kate Winslet nominated for Titanic her
second nomination last Oscar winner
Jeremy Irons Helena bonham-carter lovely
Best Actress nominee new Barrymore Jack
Lemmon joyful Oscar accepted Cuba
Gooding jr. Angelica Houston Austin
recipient Prizzi's honor
big original double-oh-seven Sean
Connery
- former Oscar winners Kathy Bates and
Dustin Hoffman meg Ryan and then it's
grade Kim Basinger and Alec Baldwin
[Applause]
[Music]
Antonio Banderas and Melanie Griffith
[Music]
the lovely Mira Sorvino
[Applause]
heaven be as in that villain goes
presenting tinnitus making her third
Oscar appearance Madonna Arnold
Schwarzenegger and Maria Shriver
[Applause]
welcome to the 70th annual Academy Award
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
the president of the Academy of Motion
Picture Arts and Sciences producer
Robert Raymond
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the world's most enthusiastic movie fans
are those people who make movies because
one of them might welcome all the others
of you to our annual awards
this is Oscars 70th birthday and we
baked the cake big enough for the
millions who share our enthusiasm I want
to thank all of the artists who have
contributed to the night show and a
special thanks to Jerry Goldsmith who
composed fanfare two Oscars for our 70th
anniversary
[Music]
because I'm as anxious to get to the
party as you that's my speech now let's
celebrate our great year in the movies
good night
[Applause]
[Music]